the universe is full of amazing
contrasts
most of space expanses are code lifeless
vacuum
paradoxically it harbors clumps of
surprisingly hot material which we call
stars
drifting deliberately through its
limitless stretches for billions of
years they illumine the fathomless
depths of space and undergo slow and
mostly subtle changes as time goes by
however
sometimes space is illuminated with an
incredibly big flash
a giant star suddenly shrinks to a
thousandth of its original size only to
destroy everything around it in a
violent explosion moments later the
shock wave with a power beyond our
imagination rips the star apart
and with its volume blown away and gone
the only things that remain around are
clumps of scorching hot gas and where
the star has just been there remains
just a tiny object made up of
exceptionally dense material with
bizarre and extraordinary properties
this is how stars die
violently and in the blink of an eye
[Music]
the end of 2019 astronomical
observatories report a sudden decrease
in the luminosity of the star known as
betelgeuse observations show that its
luminosity dropped to 36 of the standard
value within a matter of a couple of
months
some scientists are talking about an
upcoming supernova which will be the
brightest object in the night sky
disturbingly the gamma-ray flow emitted
by the explosion is thought to be
potentially dangerous for life on our
planet
april 2020
astronomers assure the general public
that beetlejuice has recovered its
luminosity to the standard value it may
still go supernova at any moment but
there is no way to predict this event
with any degree of certainty assumptions
about reasons for such anomalous fading
are put forward
according to the most popular hypothesis
it was caused by a giant cloud of gas
and dust ejected by beetlejuice in the
direction of the sun very recently
june 2021
the assumption is confirmed by data from
earth-based telescopes
astronomers keep observing the object
while astrophysicists model out the
processes occurring in its interior
before we attempt to get to the bottom
of what was taking place
it's a good idea to be aware of what
beetlejuice is like
this object falls into the category of
red supergiants and is in the final
stage of its life cycle according to
today's theory of stellar evolution
with its luminosity and radius
constantly changing its outer layers are
highly unstable
the star regularly emits millions of
tons of scorching gas into space
and this forms gargantuan prominences
as they cool off they contribute to the
gas nebula surrounding beetlejuice
the star's mass is around 17 times that
of the sun and its diameter has by now
been gauged only roughly at 700 to 880
times that of the sun hypothetically if
beetlejuice were to be placed in the
center of our system it would swallow up
all the planets as far as mars as well
as most of the asteroid belt it should
be mentioned that the star has no
clearly defined edge because its outer
layers are extremely rarified
besides the object is shrouded in a
gargantuan gas nebula made up of cooled
off prominences or protuberances and
particles of stellar wind at the same
time the density of stellar matter on
the conventional edges of the star is
only slightly higher than that of the
nebula
beetlejuice is a remarkably bright star
its minimal luminosity is 90 000 times
higher than that of the sun while its
maximum luminosity is a staggering 150
000 times higher
interestingly the star's temperature is
not that great considering it ranges
from 3400 to 3800 kelvin which
corresponds to the red spectral band
there are barely predictable processes
running in the unstable outer layers of
the star they are capable of elaborately
changing the object's luminosity
the main pulsation period of the star is
approximately 420 days but less distinct
cycles of longer and smaller periods can
be singled out too
besides unpredictable flares and dimming
of the star can be observed from time to
time because this star is so unstable it
is extremely difficult to calculate the
distance between us according to the
estimates offered by the coriolis
satellite in 2020 the distance between
the sun and beetlejuice is anything from
500 to 650 light years
according to today's notions of stellar
evolution
betelgeuse would have formed around
eight and a half million years ago and
its original mass wouldn't have been
over 20 solar masses
its life cycle would have started in a
giant cloud of interstellar gas that
would have been gradually compressed and
heated up by gravity forces that is how
the protostar the progenitor of
betelgeuse was born at a certain point
the temperature and pressure in its
interior reached high enough values to
unleash a chain reaction of hydrogen
transforming into helium
moments later
the thermonuclear interaction consumed
the entire astronomical body and a new
star flared up in the night sky
this is how the longest period in the
life of any star begins
the main sequence stage
throughout this time merging of hydrogen
atoms nuclei that produce helium is the
main energy source for them
admittedly the heavier a star the faster
this process runs
life expectancy of massive stars like
beetlejuice is a measly several million
years whereas red dwarves remain active
for billions of years
either way
over 90 percent of a star's life passes
in the main sequence stage
gradually accumulating
helium is drawn to the object's center
to form a helium core what happens to
the star next depends almost entirely on
its mass for example stars with masses
not over 20 percent that of the sun do
not go supernova at the end of their
existence
unlike more massive stars having
eventually run out of almost all of
their hydrogen they slowly turn into
blue dwarfs hot and comparatively small
astronomical objects
however the minimal time it takes to
complete this transformation is around a
trillion years which is 72 times the
assumed age of the universe which is why
it is doubtful that any blue dwarf will
be discovered today
after hydrogen supplies are depleted
thermonuclear reactions in the star will
stop and it will become a white dwarf
made up of 99 of helium
ahead are trillions of years of slow
fading and cooling until a tepid black
dwarf is left instead which is barely
visible through telescopes
if an object's mass lies in the range
from point two to eight solar masses its
evolution goes through more elaborate
processes helium which is produced as a
result of thermonuclear reactions adds
to the star's core while gravity forces
compress it and heat it up more and more
at a certain point there occurs a
reaction of helium nuclei is merging
which produces carbon the star begins to
expand its radius grows as well and the
temperature of the outer layers drops in
this case the object turns into a red
giant or sub-giant
comparatively light stars with masses
not exceeding 50 percent that of the sun
can at sustain conditions necessary for
the chain reaction of helium and carbon
transformations like these are quite
irregular in such objects
as for heavier objects reactions
occurring the star's core may run longer
and produce not only carbon and oxygen
but also heavier elements
like nickel and iron
eventually the star sheds its outer
layers and what is left is a white dwarf
enveloped in a planetary nebula if the
initial mass of the original star wasn't
more than half that of the sun it will
mostly be made up of helium with just a
small ratio of heavier elements in its
composition
if on the other hand the star was
heavier than that the white dwarf would
be mostly made up of oxygen and carbon
however with the original star having
been heavy enough it will include neon
magnesium and even iron
evolution of massive objects has its
laws
the heavier star the more massive its
core
with the mass of a star eight or more
times that of the sun its core might get
over the so-called chandra shaker limit
which is 1.4 times the mass of the sun
in this case forces of internal
electromagnetic repulsion are not strong
enough to compensate for gravitational
compression it takes a few seconds for
the core to shrink pulling the outer
layers in its wake
the exceptionally powerful compression
heats up the core to temperatures of
hundreds of millions kelvin and
literally crams electrons into atoms
nuclei
this turns part of the electrons into
neutrons and produces great amounts of
neutrinos
even a dense material like that is not
able to hold back the most elusive
particle in the universe
in a few seconds time neutrinos break
away from the collapsing star and escape
taking some thermal energy with them
as a result the star experiences
extremely powerful internal pressure
as the closely packed protons repel each
other with a great force
that is why the core goes on to expand
as rapidly as it shrank a few seconds
previously and this produces a
tremendous shock wave in the material
surrounding it
as a result a tremendously powerful
explosion occurs which is capable of
hurling the star's outer layers enormous
distances away its flames can unleash
reactions that are impossible anywhere
else that is how heavy elements are
produced like gold lead or uranium the
nebula formed as a by-product gradually
cools off and disperses to form separate
clouds which are later compressed by
gravity forces and transform into new
stars and planets
where the star has been there remains a
tiny but extremely heavy object referred
to as a neutron star if the original
star's mass was over 18 to 20 times that
of the sun on explosion its core is
supposed to shrink to form a black hole
a bizarre object that distorts time and
space around it mathematical modelling
shows that particularly large stars with
masses over a hundred times the mass of
the sun may hypothetically be destroyed
by the blast completely
in this case all the material they're
made up of will be scattered by the
shock wave many light years around or
else be transformed into extremely
powerful electromagnetic radiation
an electromagnetic impulse from a
supernova is capable of covering
hundreds of light years
at first the radiation is characterized
by incredible force annihilating all
living things on its way
[Music]
however with the covered distance
growing the density of the flow
decreases and the lethal rays gradually
disperse in space
estimates show that a star similar to
betelgeuse may be a threat to anything
within the radius of up to 100 light
years
it is absolutely impossible to tell when
this star will go supernova but it is
likely to do so in the nearest hundred
thousand years according to some
estimates beetlejuice may flare up as
brightly as the full moon the dying star
will remain the dominating object in our
night sky for a while and then will
gradually fade
the object will not be visible to the
naked eye anymore and only the most
powerful telescopes will be able to
distinguish the radiation emitted by the
tiny neutron star if the mass of
beetlejuice is actually bigger than is
assumed now
it may leave a black hole after going
supernova
in this scenario the energy flare will
be by far smaller and the site much less
impressive
either way there is no threat to the
earth beetlejuice lies too far away from
the solar system
and a gamma-ray flare that will
accompany the supernova will not cause
us any harm the material ejected by the
explosion will reach the environs of our
system only in 6 million years
its speed is estimated to be around 13
kilometers per second and will be
thwarted by solar wind before getting as
far as the inner areas of the system
with all today's successes in science
the dark depths of limitless space still
harbor myriads of mysteries and hazards
that is why people keep studying the sky
as diligently as thousands of years ago
in search of answers to their questions
and the gloomy boundless abyss of
interstellar space is as scary as it is
appealing
who knows
maybe at some point it will provide an
answer to a really major question
[Music]
you